>>> WELL, HAVE YOU LOOKED AT THE
CONTRACT?
>> CHARLIE, LOOK.
WE SELL COMPUTERS.
YOU'RE MY BUSINESS PARTNER AT
OUR COMPUTER COMPANY.
OKAY?
SO, LET'S GET THE DEAL DONE.
>> HEY, DAD.
CAN I TALK TO YOU?
>> OF COURSE, SON.
IS THERE A PROBLEM?
>> YOU SEE --
[ PHONE RINGING ]
>> HOLD THAT THOUGHT.
CHARLIE?
NO, NO, NO.
THAT'S NOT GONNA WORK.
WE'RE IN THE COMPUTER BUSINESS
AFTER ALL.
OKAY, SO CALL ME BACK.
AND CHARLIE, YOU'RE ONE HELL OF
A PARTNER.
[ PHONE BEEP ]
YOU WERE SAYING, SON?
>> WELL, MY FRIEND FAILED THE
MATH TEST.
AND I GUESS I'M JUST WONDERING
WHAT YOU'D SAY TO HIM IF HE WERE
YOUR SON.
>> WELL, I KNOW HE WOULDN'T BE
PLAYING VIDEO GAMES FOR THE NEXT
FEW YEARS.
>> DAD, I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU
SOMETHING.
SO I --
>> JUST ONE SECOND, KIDDO.
TALK TO ME.
WAIT, WHO IS THIS?
CHARLIE.
♪♪♪
♪ DAD
HE'S LIKE A HERO TO ME
ALWAYS HAS BEEN AND
ALWAYS WILL BE ♪
♪ I WORSHIP THE GROUND
THAT HE WALKS ON
JUST WISH HE
WOULD TRASH THAT PHONE THAT HE
TALKS ON ♪
♪ DAD, YOU'RE OBSESS ED
WITH WORK
DON'T YOU KNOW ♪
♪ YOUR OBSESSION HURTS
LOOK AT WHAT THIS
THING DID TO YOU
IS THIS THE ONLY ♪
♪ WAY THAT I TO GET
THROUGH TO YOU
DAD, SO BUSY
ALL THE TIME ♪
♪ B-B-BUSY ALL
THE TIME
DAD, SO BUSY
ALL THE TIME ♪
♪ I-I-I WANNA
HANG WITH YOU
EVER SINCE THE DAY
DAD GOT THE PHONE ♪
>> CHARLIE.
♪ I GOT TO SAY
I'VE FELT SO ALONE
HELLO DAD
DON'T YOU KNOW ♪
♪ THAT YOU'RE NEEDED
WE'RE SORRY
THE CONNECTION
WITH YOUR DAD ♪
♪ CANNOT BE COMPLETED
ALSO I'M NOT POPULAR
AND GIRLS DON'T LIKE ME
IT ALL FEELS VERY BAD ♪
♪ NOW HERE'S COLBY
RAPPING ABOUT DAD
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
COLBY ♪
♪ D-A-D-D-Y
THAT'S THE GUY
ALWAYS HAVE A SHOULDER
FOR YOU TO CRY ♪
♪ CATCHING THE BALL
CATCHING THE FISH
CATCHING TIME WITH POPS
IS A BEAUTIFUL WISH ♪
♪ SINCE BACK IN THE DAY
DADS HAVE BEEN KILLING IT
BARBEQUE BOSS WITH THE BURGERS
STRAIGHT GRILLIN IT DON'T FORGET
THE O.G. DAD SHOWING LOVE OUR
HEAVENLY FATHER LORD UP ABOVE
AMEN ♪
>> YO, IT'S NOT SUPPOSED TO BE A
RELIGIOUS THING.
IT'S ABOUT MY DAD.
>> OH, SURE.
>> DO IT LIKE WE TALKED ABOUT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> ALL RIGHT, LET'S DO THE
DANCING WE PRACTICED.
>> ONE, TWO, THREE, GET LOOSE
NOW!
♪♪♪
♪ B-B-BUSY ALL THE TIME ♪
♪ I-I-I WANNA HANG WITH YOU ♪
♪ DAD ♪
>> WE'RE DONE HERE.
RIGHT, SON?
>> NO, DAD.
I THINK I'M DONE.
I FAILED THE MATH TEST.
>> LET ME CALL YOU BACK.
SCOTTY, WHY DIDN'T YOU TELL ME?
>> I TRIED TO.
BUT I THINK YOUR LINE WAS BUSY.
♪♪♪
>> I'VE BEEN IGNORING MY OWN
SON.
♪ WHAT HAVE I BECOME
IT ALL BEGAN WHEN THE -- ♪
[ PHONE RINGING ]
>> CHARLIE, TALK TO ME.
YEAH.
NO, NO, NO.
I'M JUST DOING A RAP FOR MY SON
SCOTTY.
YEAH, IT'S TO A FUNKY BEAT.
REALLY?
OH, HELL, I CAN GET THERE RIGHT
AWAY.
LET ME JUST DO MY LAST LINE FOR
THE RAP.
YEAH.
♪ AND THAT'S WHY
I'M YOUR DAD ♪
YEAH.
CHARLIE.
>> CAN I COME?
>> SORRY SON.
NOT THIS TIME.
COLBY.
>> PRAISE THE LORD.
>> WE'RE GOING TO HAVE SOME FUN.
>> DAD.
[ DIAL TONE ]
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]